great morning everybody we the best news
welcome the best news that we the best
news but what people say about you
Khaled is about your positivity and your
optimism and I've seen you many places
many times and you always have that
where did that come from you a happy kid
always um you know obviously you know
I'm God's child you know God is the
greatest and my parents always treated
me with love and showed me love they
also showed me how to work hard and they
also showed me that you know to succeed
you know you must believe and when you
believe you succeed they encourage you
in music even when others didn't yeah
they encourage you know when I was
playing my in my turntables in the room
loud like they accepted it yeah raised
it you can you leave take it to the
garage we support I've actually seen
people tell my parents
yo why you letting your son do this and
like what you mean we love my son to be
happy and we love what he's doing it's
beautiful look at me now so you're a dad
now yes you have a two and a half year
old and the father of Assad yeah that's
right and you've who's already produced
how many of your album right now he's
executive produced two hours yeah I'm
saying and you know what so what so why
did you why did they can well I want to
answer that in a special way because
it's a point that everybody here is you
know as a parent you're supposed to set
up your son and that your son your
daughter and give them security you got
to raise them with love but as my duty I
need to set up his future no you not
people have to set up their college plan
I start from birth minute he came out
the minute it's on my responsibility
make sure he's good if I open a hotdog
stand tomorrow
it's his if I meet talking on this show
I'm representing my son yeah I'm saying
so the way I walk the way I breathe the
way I move I represent my son and when
my son came in my life
and I became greater yeah you said
everything that he said we the best
thing recently so this is yeah you know
I'm telling you the truth it's so crazy
because my album came out Friday May 17
yeah on everything I love my son my
queen woke me up by 8 in the morning and
brought my son in my bed and he kept
getting me hit me
started saying we the best we the best
first time we ever said it yeah that's
gone yes don't feel pretty good what a
cry like this is like this is like real
real I'm telling you my real life yeah I
only know how to tell you in a real way
yeah I also already helps you pick the
songs on the album he x hits yet my son
he has uh he you know when I when he
smiles and he starts like doing stuff
like this I know it's one of them big
smashes that the world I'm gonna embrace
then there's some deep songs that he
actually has a serious face yeah yeah I
wonder where he gets that because this
is the thing about you people saying
well keys have met a major producer he's
a music mogul but I want people
understand when you went on the Beyonce
tour that was a game-changer he would
been a life changing you had been a
successful DJ but what happened when you
when they asked you to be on that tour
well when they asked me to be on the
tour I couldn't believe it what do they
want you to do there's that York I want
you to open up for Beyonce yeah you know
saying I was like wow I and I thought
they were joking with me and it was
serious and when I got the opportunity
not only did I open up for Beyonce
these are sold-out stadiums yeah got to
see ya and she let me do what I do
you're saying like how do you describe
what you do what I do is I bring people
together and I make people happy and I
make people feel a certain spirit of joy
and I make people how could I say just
words off your word music is one thing
but the way I present the music the way
I perform the way I DJ the way I bring
out special artists and they bring out a
collaborator above a bunch of artists
that takes love collaboration with
Nipsey Hussle
yes exactly where they got that via that
video now is haunting to me shot two
days before his death
no take us through that why that's
important to you you know working week
first of all thank you God for let me
work with a great king like Nipsey
Hussle except I express love and a
message you've got on a prophet like
Alma prophet
short when I speak to Nipsey the way he
speaks his spirit and before we made the
record we was talking about family our
kids I asked him I thought he had Arabic
mixed in them and then he told me where
he's from and he told me what his name
man this is all before we made the song
and we was talking about
entrepreneurship and how to you know I
says leader is how we this beautiful
stuff and then while we was walking to
the studio I was like man one day man
you should put that in a song because it
was really special and my favorite
artists like jay-z and Diggy and POC
they always you know told their life
stories of the upbringing and where they
come from in a special way that you felt
and I call that big boy rap and that's
what Nipsey Hussle and I'd say you look
very dapper today wait waters I think is
working for you oh yeah wait what how
has it changed you first of all it's the
new Weight Watchers yeah and it's a
program called freestyle and it changed
my life because I think I'm like lost
over 47 pounds Wow awesome we're gonna
have to forgive me we're gonna have to
go DJ Khaled thank you so much for
laying with us before we go we'll show
you a heartwarming tradition at a New
York Hospital I don't want him to leave
I don't eat
[Laughter]